Im Moment geht ja die 16/8-Diät rund.
Die Idee: Einfach nur innerhalb 8 Stunden
essen und dann 16 Stunden Pause machen.
Aber wirkt das wirklich oder ist das alles
nur Einbildung?
Ein Forschungsteam von der University of Surrey
ist der These jetzt nachgegangen und hat sie
überprüft.
Allerdings gibt es einen Haken.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht‘s!
Herzlich willkommen!
In einer 10-wöchigen Studie untersuchte das
Forschungsteam wie sich die Änderung der
Essenszeiten auf das Gewicht und andere Faktoren
auswirkt.
Die Teilnehmer und Teilnehmerinnen wurden
in zwei Gruppen eingeteilt - diejenigen, die
das Frühstück um 90 Minuten verzögern und
90 Minuten früher zu Abend essen sollten,
und diejenigen, die wie gewöhnlich Mahlzeiten
aßen als Kontrollgruppe.
Im Gegensatz zu früheren Studien musste sich
niemand an eine strenge Diät halten und alle
konnten frei essen was sie wollten, nur nicht
wann sie wollten.
Obwohl es keine Einschränkungen gab stellten
das Forschungsteam fest, dass diejenigen,
die ihre Essenszeiten änderten, insgesamt
weniger zu sich nahmen als die Kontrollgruppe.
Dieses Ergebnis wurde durch Antworten auf
einen Fragebogen gestützt.
57 Prozent der Befragten bestätigte, dass
sie weniger aßen.
Gründe: vermindertem Appetit und generell
weniger Essgelegenheiten.
Und tatsächlich ist der Effekt der geänderten
Esszeiten frappierend.
Das Forschungsteam fand heraus, dass diejenigen,
die ihre Essenszeiten änderten, im Durchschnitt
mehr als doppelt so viel Körperfett verloren,
als diejenigen in der Kontrollgruppe, die
zu den üblichen Zeiten aßen.
Wenn diese Pilotdaten in größeren Studien
wiederholt werden können, so das Forschungsteam,
besteht die Möglichkeit, dass die zeitbeschränkte
Nahrungsaufnahme einen breiten Nutzen sogar
insgesamt für die Gesundheit hat.
Wow!
Studienleiter Dr.
Jonathan Johnston dazu: „Obwohl diese Studie
klein ist, hat sie uns wertvolle Einblicke
gegeben, wie geringfügige Änderungen unserer
Essenszeiten unseren Körper beeinflussen
können.
Die Verringerung des Körperfetts verringert
unsere Chancen, an Fettleibigkeit und verwandten
Erkrankungen zu erkranken, und ist daher für
die Verbesserung der allgemeinen Gesundheit
von entscheidender Bedeutung.“
Doch es gibt einen Haken, denn 57 Prozent
der Befragten meinen, dass sie die neuen Essenszeiten
nicht länger als die vorgeschriebenen 10
Wochen hätten einhalten können.
Ihr Argument: Die geänderten Essenszeiten
seien nicht mit dem Familien- und Sozialleben
vereinbar.
43 Prozent der Teilnehmer und Teilnehmerinnen
würden jedoch in Erwägung ziehen, mit flexibleren
Essenszeiten fortzufahren.
Dazu Johnston: „Wie wir bei diesen Teilnehmern
gesehen haben, ist es jedoch schwierig, Fasten-Diäten
zu befolgen, die möglicherweise nicht immer
mit dem Familien- und Sozialleben vereinbar
sind.
Wir müssen daher sicherstellen, dass sie
flexibel und förderlich für das wirkliche
Leben sind, da die potenziellen Vorteile solcher
Diäten offensichtlich sind.“
Es scheint hier also wirklich ein Weg gefunden
worden zu sein, mit einem ganz einfachen Trick
gesünder leben zu können.
Allerdings gibt es noch etwas, was so richtig
gesund ist.
Abnehmen und Muskeln aufbauen.
Unbedingt draufklicken.
Das aktuelle Video von Bytethinks!
Nach etwas mehr als einem Jahr gibt es wieder
Videos von Finn!
Also unbedingt abonnieren und ansonsten bis
dann, bleibt dran!